a must-have for any world war two video
game the m1 garand is a huge part of
military history and the arsenal of pop
culture weapons
it was a tool that helped the allied
fight in the second world war and has
since been seen on screen in the arms of
everyone from captain america to heath
ledger's joker however its modern
popularity is mainly spurred on
by this sound
but what about the rest of the goran's
history the myths behind it and the
impact it's had on games over 80 years
after its invention well i'm here at the
royal armouries museum in the uk to find
out more about its grand legacy
[Music]
the greatest battle implement ever
devised the words of united states
general george s patton on the m1 garand
in an hour historical piece of
correspondence to the war office's chief
of ordnance major general levin h
campbell the rifle has been described as
the single most significant small arms
development in the history of modern
warfare and despite its reputation as an
iconic american firearm the m1 garand is
actually the invention of quebec born
canadian american john cantius garrett
born in 1888 garen cultivated an
interest in firearms and machinery from
an early age and began designing
firearms as a hobby in 1917 while
working as a master gauge and gun
experimenter he developed the m1919
patent model spa 915 automatic machine
gun and though development was too late
for the first world war garen was
retained as an engineer at the
springfield armory in 1919 a role he
would continue until his retirement some
34 years later in springfield garin
would begin work designing a
gas-operated 30 caliber semi-automatic
rifle this was a significant development
on the standard bolt action rifles used
at the time and while development took
15 years in 1932 garen painted the
semi-automatic 30 caliber m1 rifle later
known as the m1 ground less than four
years later the m1 became the us army
standard introduced in 1936 which might
not sound very early for self-loading
rifle technology but in terms of adopt
adoption by the whole of an armed force
it absolutely is the united states was
the first to do that the first major
power to do that although mexico got
there first with the mondragon
rifle but only a few thousand of those
were made and not all of them were even
shipped
so the self-loading rifle technology
goes back to the very end of the 19th
century but it took more than a
generation for this thing to become
reliable safe and trusted so garand is
kind of the the ground zero for the
modern service rifle of course the
majority of rifles in the second world
war were still being manually operated
for a u.s soldier to go in with the
garand where you if you need to you can
fire it from the hip all eight shots as
fast as you can spam the trigger or even
accurate shots at range but without
having to change your position and hold
and aim is such such a leap forward i
can't stress how important it is
despite over six and a half million m1
rifles being made garen never received
any royalties from his design as he
transferred all rights to his invention
to the u.s government in 1936.
in the 1970s bills were presented to
congress to award him a hundred thousand
us dollars in appreciation for his work
but alas they did not pass he was
however awarded a medal for meritorious
service in 1941 and a u.s government
medal for merit in 1944. mass production
began in the mid-1930s but due to some
technical issues it wasn't until 1940
that the springfield armory went into
full production of the m1 by the end of
1941 the us army was fully equipped and
after the u.s entered the second world
war winchester began producing
stockpiles of the m1 rifles too in
september 1945 world war ii came to an
end and in that time over 4 million m1
garan rifles had been produced
the grand afforded the us forces a
significant advantage it was fast to
both fire and reload and its
semi-automatic operation meant the
soldiers could more easily reacquire
their targets after each fired round it
was also dependable easier to use and
easier to maintain than the previously
issued springfield bolt action rifles as
you can see from one of the original
1940s training videos though it was a
technological leap the operational rifle
was simple enough for the every man
soldier to use effectively in fact one
man firing at goran can do nearly as
much damage as three men using the old
type springfield rifle critical to the
design of this weapon was its use of an
n-block clip this crude looking piece of
sheet metal was able to hold eight
rounds at a time and would automatically
eject as part of the rifle's mechanical
operation upon firing the last round it
is from this clip that the most iconic
and recognizable element of the m1
garand was born
the ping
so it's not deliberately designed to
make that noise obviously it's a side
effect of how it is designed
and that is because there's a lesser
known form of clip so a clip is a feed
device without a spring
as opposed to a magazine which has a
spring in it so so the garand has its
magazine built in and it's fed by a clip
just like a stripper clip on a action
rifle where you push in the rounds from
the clip the difference is the clip is
held within the gun
you can you can replicate some of that
noise just by flexing it and and
throwing it in the air and there are
stories of gi's doing that to
make the enemy think that their rifle is
empty or at least one story of that but
that real resonant pinging sound
has to come from a firing rifle so i can
totally see why some veterans did think
that it was a disadvantage but it would
be a very specific set of circumstances
where the clip
ping would give you away while the
validity of these stories and myths are
up to debate the ping was considered
significant enough that there were
experiments in creating quieter plastic
m-block clips for the garand but this
research never amounted to much however
one thing remains certain the ping is an
iconic and instantly recognizable part
of the m1's real world history and its
pop culture identity but where exactly
is this ringing ping coming from so now
we've got one in front of us can you
show us where exactly the ping
comes from
i can now normally of course you load a
full clip of eight rounds
but rather than fling
fairly solid
rounds towards your head i'm going to
set that aside i appreciate that and
i'll load an empty clip so sort of
simulating the end of a string of fire
so we'll set this up by
locking the rifle open which it does
automatically
put in our empty clip
and then being a little bit careful
load it in bear in mind that when we
fire the last shot in real life you'd
have the last empty case coming out as
well
but the main noise comes from and get
ready to duck
didn't quite manage to catch that one if
i got that it was
so there you go and it will it will stay
open
so lock to the rear ready for the next
full clip
which you then shove in shove in with
your thumb so as you're loading it it's
worth talking about the
other element that surrounds the grand
of the grand thumb
i don't want you to get garand thumb but
if you can
sort of demonstrate it without hurting
yourself yeah there are other places on
youtube to go if you want to see that
yeah see people willfully hurting
themselves yeah so this is a direct
symptom of
this very clever loading system
in the all you're going to do is shove
in more rounds and if the the gun is in
the right sort of
fatal
the working parts will go forward on
their own even
which is part of the problem i suppose
so to load another clip or even if
you're just trying to empty the gun and
show clear for inspection um you have to
shove your thumb in it and you've seen
what happens when that slams
shut if the thumb was in it you can see
how it sounds like it would hurt yeah
yeah there's a lot of spring power
there's solid steel flying forward at
quite the rate so if you do it wrong and
you don't put the heel of your hand on
there when you load it maybe you're in a
rush there's a war on after all
you could easily catch the tip of yours
i think that would be the most painful
is catching the very tip of your thumb
in there it's making my hands feel
uncomfortable following world war ii
firearms development continued both in
the u.s and across the globe after leaps
in weapons technology were made during
the conflict one of these was the german
sturmgiver the world's first
mass-produced assault rifle despite
being less powerful than the m1 the
sturmgover or stg44 was able to fire in
fully automatic and implemented a
detachable box magazine that fired 30
rounds of 792 by 33 millimeter a much
higher capacity than the m1's eight
round m block clip but due to the
success of the garand and the advances
both the m1 and stg44 made many nations
and manufacturers took inspiration from
them for their own firearms development
weapons like the fal and the ak-47 have
direct technical connections to both the
garand and the stg but beyond this the
garand and scg served more as a design
benchmark for just about every country
and manufacturer who proceeded to adopt
either full power modernized garands
with higher capacity and emergency auto
capability like the american m14 or
something closer to the stg concept like
the soviet ak as firearms development
continued it was clear that weapons
would be built more around the ability
to put down sustained automatic fire and
the use of intermediate lower power
rounds to sustain that fire neither of
which were in the garen's description
despite falling out of use in the years
following world war ii the m1 garand
lived on in our pop culture the m1
garen's first appearance on the silver
screen was in the american action drama
war movie wake island released in 1942
just one year after the usa entered the
second world war but in the decades
following the m1 would of course feature
in hundreds of war films and dramas when
i think of the m1 garand my mind
conjures images of classic 60s war
movies the incredible d-day landing
scene from saving private ryan the
charge of major richard winters and
bandon brothers and of course the
countless times i fired the virtual
versions in dozens of video games its
first appearances in gaming were minor
background roles like in the cutscenes
of the 1998 strategy title commandos
behind enemy lines or in the hands of
allied infantry npcs in the 1999 shooter
world war ii gi but its big break onto
our crt tvs and home consoles came with
the release of ea and dreamworks
interactive's medal of honor the
original idea for medal of honor came
from director and producer steven
spielberg just three months after his
world war ii epic saving private ryan
finished filming spielberg was pitching
dreamworks interactive the story of a
video game set in the same era the idea
for medal of honor originated from
seeing his son max playing goldeneye on
his nintendo 64 combined with
spielberg's own fascination and interest
with the second world war while the
final game would be written by peter
hirschmann dale dye was brought on board
as military adviser died also worked
with spielberg on saving private ryan
and these combined minds would work to
create a game with as much military
authenticity as possible and while the
game's arsenal aims to create a level of
detail that was unprecedented for the
time the goran's first big game was
missing its most iconic thing for the
rifle
does not ping
another pop culture trope that has
followed the garen for years after its
original appearance is the incorrect
assumption that the rifle cannot reload
unless it has been fired until empty
interestingly the very first medal of
honor did allow you to reload the rifle
at will whether it was empty or not
of course it was a fudged reload that
was ever present in the simplistic
shooters of the 90s where the weapon
disappears off screen and returns full
once more but you could do it it was
three years later with the release of
medal of honor allied assault where the
m1 garand would return with its
signature ping but forcing players to
fire until empty in order to reload what
was the decision behind this design was
it limited resources to model such an
interaction as the fidelity of games
were increasing or was it off the back
of the m1 manual of arms where
instructions call for the rifle to be
fired until empty and then recharged
quickly while we may not know for sure
what we do know is that due to this
implementation in game and the
popularity of the title and of course
the growing excitement for world war ii
shooters this incorrect trait of the
garen would follow it to its appearance
in the very first battlefield game and
to the very first call of duty as well
as a result this misconception of the
garen's reload would stay with it for
years to come not until 2008's call of
duty world of war did game start to
implement partial reloads of the weapon
again the success of these titles
influenced designs and trends in the
games that followed them and for the
most part games were building partial
reloads back into the rifle wherever the
grand appeared
the ping of the garand is still one of
the first things that players think of
with the weapon and it's obviously a
touchstone in our games developers know
that it will be missed and commented on
if not implemented and the sound alone
is enough to engage and excite consumers
even to the point where it's used in the
menus and marketing of call of duty
world war ii
my perception is it's been done right by
for the most part most of its depictions
are pretty solid the rear sight aperture
is always nearly always huge i think so
as not to obstruct the player's field of
view but in real life that would make
the rifle substantially less accurate
but yeah overall you get the correct
round count you get reasonably correct
behavior on screen in terms of
animations reload animations are
generally good you could probably
quibble over how
powerful a given implementation of it is
in a given game by being
so famous i think it's hard to go get it
too wrong otherwise the player base will
notice the impact that the m1 garand had
on the real world cannot be overstated
it was an impactful implement of battle
that served the allied forces in one of
the darkest times in modern history and
while that cannot and will not be
forgotten we can also appreciate that it
found a more peaceful and sometimes more
esoteric life and legacy in the world of
our pop culture
[Music]
for me world war ii video games and
movies was something that ignited an
interest in military history i'm sure
many of you watching have had a similar
experience the trend of world war ii
shooters has ebbed and flowed but a
constant throughout damn near all of
them was the ping of the m1 rifle for me
it became almost comforting in a weird
way making me feel like i was back in
the familiar ground or the original call
of duty battlefield or medal of honor
it's always been a known entity that i
could rely on in any virtual adventure
and it still never fails to spark an
essence of nostalgia with one simple
sound
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
it make sure you ping that like button
and share your thoughts in the comments
section below or you can reach out to me
directly on twitter at a regular dave
let us know what you'd like to see in
future episodes and if you want more
video game firearms content you can
watch the previous episodes of this show
or check out our weekly series of
firearms expert reacts where i show our
friends at the royal armouries a
selection of guns from our favorite
games god i think this is a garand what
have they done to you until next time
i've been your host dave dewitt thank
you so much for watching and i'll see
you in the next episode
[Applause]
[Music]
you